[Music]
sing
goodbyes s not
L you think your wife can hear you no
then why
bother Maybe I'm
Wrong you're going to die maybe not
goodbye to you my trusted friend
a new day is
Dawning new ideas new wounds New
Management we've known each other since
we
were who is this the Marquee de Gro
challenge him to single combat when a
lose it's a way
out I don't sit it the T your family
does please for
me I was the black sheep of the
family man has to look his best when
it's time to get
married or
buried I'm going to need a gun goodbye
[Music]
my if you
win the table will honor its
word you will have your
freedom
under the old laws only one can survive
failure to meet at
sunrise for result and
execution Last Words Winston just up
for I want you to find your peace
but the good death only comes after good
life you and I left a good life behind a
long time ago my
[Music]
friend
your days of fighting for the so-called
greater good are
over this is our chance to control the
truth the concepts of right and wrong
for everyone for centuries to come
you're fighting to save an ideal that
doesn't
exist never
did you need to pick a
sign
[Music]
I
here's the thing we're a team of
Thieves then when you do
this you're bound to make
enemies sometimes those enemies come
looking for
Revenge truth be
told we help the wrong person steal the
wrong
thing we didn't mean to unleash the
greatest evil the world has ever
known but we're going to fix it so how
do we pull that
off uh figure it out over a drink
probably best you need to give us a
fighting chance we're going to need
strength you got this right I know you
don't we also need
courage
Magic
and
you what is that again it's all
there
let be
warned there is evil
here I'm glad he's on our side want to
hold
on want to
hold want to hold on this one's
dangerous but whatever
happens we'll be
ready what is it exactly that you bring
to this I'm a planter I make plans
you've already made the pl so if the
existing plan fails I make a new plan so
you make plans that fail no he also
plays the loot not relevant
[Music]
I miss the
desert I miss the
sea and I miss waking up every
morning wondering what wonderful
Adventure the new day will bring to
us
those days have come and gone Perhaps
Perhaps
[Music]
not I don't believe in
magic but a few times in my
life I've seen
things things I can't
explain and I've come to believe it's
not so much what you
believe that's how hard you believe
[Music]
it who is this man I'm her Godfather
related
get
back we were gone for quite a
while but no matter what happens
next the Galaxy still needs its
Guardians hello we come in peace
come on Drax seriously dude no
Noy don't
forget where we came
from we have been running
our whole
lives Pete I'm done
[Applause]
running we'll all fly away
together one last
time into the f
ever a beautiful
sky we
[Music]
[Applause]
are and we kill anyone who gets in our
way not kill anyone kill a few people
kill no people kill one guy one stupid
guy who no one loves now you're just
making it sad
[Music]
a
get off the
hor this all [__] is a go
Miner we're rich
boys get down on your knees [__] him
up we got
gold
he was a finished Commander lost his
home and his family in the war he became
a oneman death
[Music]
squad he's one mean [__] that
you do not want to mess
[Music]
with
fire you'll see what happens when you
take everything from
him do you really believe that he's
Immortal no it just refuses to die how
many mines did we bury here all of
them
you and
you
this is not about who the strongest this
is about not giving
up we have a word for that in
[Music]
Finland we might have a
problem I spent the last s years of my
life living out my wildest
dreams Beyond
a
rocky my
dad this was built on their
shoulders hey my man can I help you let
me get autograph no I ain't signing an
autographs would you get off my car you
don't remember me
[Music]
huh
Dam how long were you locked up 18 Years
bro just got out last week
glad to have you back out huh I know
I've been away a long time but I kept
myself in shape I still got gas in the
tank come by the gym thank
you curious what happened with you two
iead and tell you he was like
brothers I was the best though but I
never got a chance to prove that that's
cute hey hey what you doing man H me I
know what you doing d you don't all this
do
nothing damen's fighting the world and
he's trying to hurt people I Bouch for
you you think you mad try spending half
your life in a Cell why can somebody
else live your
life I'm coming for everything you
threatening
me something is going on with you D you
was like
[Music]
family now we pass talking then maybe
you just have to find out what I got to
do some on my method you might disagree
with me these are Family Ties I
recognize mine I know that they needed
me traumatic stress watch it manifest
got my only fear I ain't scared of that
did you hear me yet I ain't scared of
that did you hear me
yet what you going to do threaten to
take
my I need you to let all your
fear let go the
guilt let go whatever was and walk into
what is I feel those chains are breaking
yeah fear God I don't fear death no
[Music]
[Applause]
Str ni
seconds that's what I'll give you to
decide your
[Music]
fate Roberto Roberto tell me what did
you do back
home government work I'm retired man or
you who my
bny because of these people I'm
beginning to understand real peace and
I'm starting to believe St this is where
I'm supposed to
be what happens here happens you many
times the
mafia they like cancer no
kill should say out of other people's
business whatever it is you and your
friends do do it somewhere else you
warning me I'm preparing is that a time
mix no it's
a that's the median nerve that I'm
compressing that's a level three you
don't want it to go to a level
four I seem like a man who understands
violence I like this place you can't
take that from
me I can take anything I
want
police found multiple dead bodies on
that farm in Sicily did you kill
[Music]
him 9
seconds do I look like a
[Music]
killer
I know that this road has been very
hard and yet here you are building This
Magnificent
family what's going on in that head of
yous something little pie of is said dad
they're not afraid of
anything but I
am I'm afraid of losing someone I
love Dominic
tetto you're about to learn all all
about
fear
boom you built such a beautiful life
filled with love and family I never got
that
chance you stole that from
me my
future my
family and
now I'm going to break
[Music]
yours Peace by peace
[Applause]
[Music]
peace he's coming for you with
everything what's the plan Don I'm not
sure
anymore one of us might not come back
from
this but we have to
fight never except death when suffering
is
old
incoming danger too many with
us it's a set up he's trying to tear us
apart our situation is TI one what do
winning used to be about winning we
raced for
[Music]
respect today I raced this stop the
blood
[Music]
bath that's the problem with having such
a big family how do you choose the ones
you
save Let's
[Music]
[Applause]
Race you still know how to
drive
what do you
think it's show time here we
go game recognizes
[Music]
game I'm coming for you
son here they come you will never be
able to break my my
family
[Music]
no good morning sunshine you got to be
kidding
me
Captain torren flight Commander how can
I help you fugitive
extradition oh is he dangerous what did
he do homicide 15 years ago I don't want
to scare the rest of the passengers I'm
afraid you're stuck with this Captain
get them on board let's have a good
[Music]
flight we're cutting right through the
top of the
storm let's keep everybody in their
seats no exceptions all right need
everyone to have their seat fly
[Music]
fashion mayday mayday mayday real Blazer
11 night we are dark is anyone near
Guard we're going to hit we're going to
hit they went down somewhere in the Jolo
Island
cluster it's run by separatists and
militias the Filipino Army won't even go
there
anymore the clock is ticking every
minute matters
we can count those minutes in lives lost
or
saved back back we don't know who it is
we don't know who it is back listen
carefully this is an emergency I'm
captain bro
torren I like this
guy Nick country Maxwell carille
England
country
I'm going to go after them my passengers
my
responsibility I'm going to need your
help you're going to need
this former military or something you
could say
that the why to look you up no one cares
what really happened but they say
redemption can be found in the most
unusual
places if you do this you'll probably
never see your family again what about
their families
I have a daughter and I have every
intention of making a
home they're going to come at us with
everything theyve
G we're getting off this
[Applause]
island
I can hear you being quiet
mom I um hope I didn't ice your game man
no one my age says those words in that
order it's just hard to see my little
man not being my little boy all the
time
yeah for years I've been taking care of
this little
boy
making sure he's
loved that he feels like he belongs
wherever he wants to
be he wants to go out into the world and
do great big
things not bad
kid and what I worry about most I love
you
miles is they won't look out for you
like
us miles
want to get out of here wherever you go
from here you have to promise to take
care of that little boy for
me make sure he never forgets where he
came
[Music]
from and he never doubts that he is
loved and he never lets
anyone tell him that he doesn't belong
there
you got to promise miles I
[Music]
promise who do you think you are
really we are supposed to be the good
guys we
are
[Music]
stand down I'm not the one to fear Prime
there is a Darkness
coming
yeah
yeah it was all a
dream pull over I'm not driving and if
you don't know
[Applause]
know
red love is the Brooklyn
W and if you don't know you know I'm
blowing up like you thought I would call
same same
it's of all the
threats from both your
past and
future it was all a dream you've never
faced anything like
this let them
come and if you don't know that you know
SC me let's get
it
[Music]
okay
boys wher have you
been we're just running errands that's
it look we're really sorry Splinter some
of the guys wanted to get pizza and I
tried to talk him out of it you ratted
us out hey don't use that word that way
I mean it's 2023 sorry
Dad
W hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted
[Music]
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that not
likely this is insane Turtle Mutant
karate te I want to know everything
about you our dad is definitely not a
giant rat that makes me feel like he's a
rat police are baffled by the recent
crime wave led by a Super Fly nobody's
ever seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
was cool no not cool a bit cool can I CH
it we take out super far and then
everyone will think we're call they'll
accept us can i k he's making a deal
tonight under the Brooklyn Bridge can
I what the y'all some little tortoises
huh I can't believe there are other
mutants you want to roll with
us humans are never going to like
us so we going to let the mutants rule
the
Earth people's Zig got to go okay um
sort of a
Twist we can't stop him we got to
try six in the morning police at my
DG can I sh
you my son Michaelangelo you have heart
Dello you have wisdom Raphael you have
bravery and Leonardo honor
enough talk I dream about fighting every
night you've got a rage problem right
it's not a problem can I you can I sh
it can I sh
you okay I want to fly let's do this
yeah you got to force it to come out
what are you you're a genius I know
what' I say
wa oh did you know what was going to
happen to my brother when you stuck him
with this world destroying
thing it's called this
scab I had no idea it would activate he
has to choose you give me that so how do
we get it to unchoose
[Music]
me post acquired who said that systems
okay going to
be
baby stop overreacting
overreacting you didn't at me I you with
that you know threat approaching
engaging H
protection and when we get him old I'm
going do it like a threat
eliminated they trying to steal cut it
out cut it out what do you think the
government is going to do when they
figure out that some kid has this
military tank down we are going to
change the world with the power of the
Scarab it belongs to
me oh he's
pissed
listen to me up to baby you got the
wrong eyy I'm a nobody I swear I down
when they see I'm Ming now baby the
world is a place to protect I have an
Arsenal at my disposal anything please
watch and learn
Kime whatever you can
imagine I can create yeah that's more
like
it
yeah that L you feel for your your
family makes you weak you're wrong my
family that's what makes me
strong oh I forgot how bad it
looks Target the
family sorry my mom I me you are
superhero
Kon y' take shots y aim up
wa you're the Blue Beetle I could use
that Arsenal right about now can never
ask hell yeah they
trying butst it down butst it down N I
advise me back
away 4 years ago I was basically
unemployed a Wanderer with no
home
but now I'm a husband and a
father and I wouldn't have it any other
way I don't know how you do it pops my
job was a little less stressful than
yours oh yeah I finally got a job I'm
the king of
[Music]
Atlantis half a billion people
from every known species in the sea call
this place
home but that doesn't mean they all like
me I'm going to kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds
dear I'm going to murder his
family and burn his kingdom to
Ash he must be stopped or a global
meltdown is
imminent I think I know someone might be
a to help
us you look
rough good job little brother High fire
do not call me
brother I cannot believe you let this
happen H well I hate this job true king
builds Bridges
right true king builds
Bridges we need to find Manta he's
different now
he's stronger than
before it's the black
Trion during King alin's time there were
Seven
Kingdoms the Trident was a curse upon
them
all the Trident start magic is
spreading he means to end the
[Music]
bloodline I don't know what lies ahead
but I can't leave our children a world
without
hope you're not as bad at this as you
think if you lead the Seven Kingdoms
will
[Music]
follow when the war
started they protected me
took better care of me than humans would
have they not people
Maya it's just
programming 10 years ago today the
artificial intelligence created to
protect us detonated a nuclear warhead
in Los
Angeles this is a fight for our very
existence Sergeant Taylor we are this
close to winning the
war
the AI are developing a super
weapon retrieve
it or they win
[Music]
to did you locate the weapon yeah it's
just a
kit are you going to heaven
no you got to be a good person to go to
heaven then we it say
we can't go to heaven cuz you're not
good and I'm not a
person do you have any idea what that
thing is she looks like a little girl
now but she's
growing Whoever has that kid wins the
war who side you want
huh what do you want sweetie for robots
to be free
oh we don't have that in the fridge how
about ice
cream
Carol Danver prodigal child of the Milky
Way Nick Fury my favorite oneeyed man of
intrigue how goes it out there I you
know cold no air
space
[Applause]
Captain Marvel the
annihilator you took everything from
me and now I'm returning the
[Music]
favor what is happening to
me she's entangled our light based
Powers so we switch places whenever we
use
them strong Theory you can absorb
light I can see it and Camala who's Cala
hi she can turn light into physical
matter which I have never heard of I
could totally show you
[Music]
no make I never be on but you
down to
sty she's targeting every planet we call
home I would never choose to bring
anybody into this you are not the only
thing standing between this and the
universe oh my God we're a team if you
want
go
higher
further
[Music]
faster who's a good kitty
Goose oh my
God I can't can you I got
it Mr
snow after everything you've seen out
there in the
world what are the Hunger Games for are
you are
you
com
the The Hunger Games they to punish the
districts those tributes don't have a
choice Your Role is to turn these
children into spectacles not survivors
free we're
live smile it's why we have
teeth imagine it was your name that they
pulled
it I just want to know that somebody
still cared about me that I was still of
value welcome to the capital you look
like you shouldn't be here I shouldn't
but I'm your Mentor a
rebel I am going to get you out of here
you want to protect
people and it's essential to accept what
human beings
are and what it takes to control
them let's see you use that famous snow
charm you seem like a good man Corina
snow I have seen what war does to
people filled with the turve becoming
prey see how quickly we become
predator
I want my enemies to see a rainbow of
Destruction engulfing the
world your monsters all of
you good luck with that poor little song
bird where is
she it's mystery and Mysteries have a
way of driving people
mad
Mr snow let me ask you one final time
what are the Hunger Games
for a
Hanging
[Music]
Tree it's the things we love most that
destroy
us I had a vision
people
burning everything destroyed it was
Athena she was doing
it I was doing it we won't let that
happen will
we I saw what you did in the
ring I knew it had to be you
say what have I told you Sienna here is
The Reincarnation of the goddess
aena and you are destined to become one
of her Guardian
Knights how does it feel to be a goddess
sometimes I feel like I'm a guest in my
own
body are you ready to start your
training the Pegasus Knight is
brave humble and committed to protecting
Athena with his
life how the hell did you do
that war that awaits us is unlike any
other
before
I must save the rest of us from
her you think I wanted any of
this his power is
liability once he learns to control it
no living man will be able to stop him
you might want to Buck
out
thought you were the only night in
[Music]
town we are a
dwarf we will annihilate
everything champions of this realm can
do nothing to stop us
you are very menacing I just want you to
know
that a lot has changed in the last few
years the wizard gave me
superpowers and then everybody got
superpowers start the bottom now we here
all right here's the situation start the
bottom the whole team here the daughters
of Atlas are coming to hunt
us children is told the power of the
Gods
you ripped it from our father's core
okay I feel like maybe I should be
riding all this down give us the powers
child your world will not survive
this you want these Powers come get them
hey
Ki start from the bottom now we here all
right start from the bottom now the
whole team here we have one job to do
save the
world
fin
I don't know how we fight powers like
this I can't do this take my powers back
you gave them to me so you can take them
back
right I spent
Millennia searching for worthy
Champion you know exactly what must be
done Billy what are you doing I have to
do this we end this now yeah
we
do start it fr the plom now we here
started fr the pl not a whole team
[Music]
H started from the bom now we
here
[Music]
[Applause]
Jonas we need your
help we're detecting increased aadc
activity 25,000 ft deep in the
trench it's an ancient ecosystem
Untouched by man whatever is down there
is trying to make its way to the surface
this is a bad idea just a little
[Music]
bit Jas we've got
company that's the biggest mag I've ever
seen biggest think anyone's ever
seen that's the apex
predator everybody make get to the
station you can make it keep
sorry three massive legs and who knows
what else have escaped the
breach I just hope it goes better than
last
time what happened last
time you don't want to
know you go go go we never seen this
before they hunted him
back we can relax this place Meg proof I
mean Jonas was always afraid of this but
I was also
[Music]
thinking me you have been down down down
down man
ooh
Barracuda location
unknown Charter
373 this is Commander Mills my ship was
hit by an undocumented
asteroid
location transporting 35
passengers location
on a long range exploratory
[Music]
Mission send
help we've crash landed on an Uncharted
Celestial body
[Music]
loation I don't know where we
are
I've located One
Survivor a
giant the atmosphere is
breathable there's something alien up
there
you need to be quiet quiet and
move
you and I are going to get home oh
finally
[Applause]
ready
on September
22nd time for music We heard you this is
going to be
fun round and
clear please make Expendables for rated
R there better be violence and lots of
it I want all the blood and guts [__]
it
first things first holy
[__] my mind is full of these brutal
fantasies
[Music]
fantasies that will now become a hellish
reality that's a great
idea well I ain't playing no
more
you're my [__] kill me you're
welcome now that's what I'm talking
about good to be
back enjoy the
show Expendables
definitely rated
R in theater September
[Music]
22nd
fore
for
a go minus
one
[Music]
ETA 5 minutes to the war zone we
must r soers
[Music]
no
go help me
[Music]
General we are
discovered
good
wait nice it's a CL
rre I'm not built like other
mens in the
masses move along now those in power
only see me as a Gro unfit for higher
office like witches at black m but I
follow in the footsteps of Alexander the
Great and
Caesar evil minds plot destruction if
you look down you'll see a
surprise once you see it you will always
want it Sorcerer of death
Construction
I must warn you I will not lead a second
of
command I will win by fire I am destined
for
greatness I found the crown of France in
the
gutter and place it at top my own
[Music]
head as is where the
burning you want to be great but you are
nothing without me say
it I believe I speak for all of us we
will all sleep again without This
Vermin whose country are we
in
fine do you know that feeling when
you're doing exactly what you put on the
earth to do the one where it's like
everything inside you is moving together
in a harmony with the
universe me neither but you know one can
hope
right wave to Mommy cuz she'll hate me
even more than she already does if you
don't I seem to recall you saying that
becoming a lawyer would only crush your
soul yeah it has I'm running a business
and right now that business is getting a
journalist and an out of
palonia no it's a oneoff no no and no
who's a journalist I have resigned my
position here at 20 grand says you
are welcome to B president Fina so nice
to meet
you we must take a selfie um you
approved
it's
great
us ow what the hell just happened your
one man's security detail happened he's
a her I'm with the president of a
country in the middle of a coup this is
the scoop of a lifetime you got to be
alive down the scoop of a lifetime you
never should have come let's go you
can't just leave
[Music]
him run
run ready to go I don't know how to stop
when you start at the bottom only way to
I'm just doing my
job do need help I get up again then I
got to win I get up again then I got to
win what nothing you still excited to
cover a coup less and less
honestly
where is
vas here is vas
go hey not the time for coaching
[Music]
man oh my
God Color Me impressed Mr Petit not
all tell me you got that
[Music]
run
are you going to answer
that it's not
[Music]
mine hello man sorry who is this there
is a bomb under your seat if
you do I have your
attention did I do something to you you
sound so guilty what do you want Drive
to this
location honey Something's Happened
there's a man who has put a bomb in the
car under our seats there are pressure
triggers we can't get out the car will
explode we're here listen very carefully
or I kill you open the glove box shoot
him why are you doing this what have I
ever done to you Dad his life or yours
Matt I'm your best
[Music]
friend You're a murderer Now
Matt you think I'm the
bomber well I guess you've had a tough
day I know that you lost a lot of money
for your clients who invested in your
fund a lot of people are worried about
[Music]
you youve got everybody's attention
mad he is still out there if you can
find him I will I'm in control here no
you're not you H my daughter son a [__]
I will kill
you what's it going to
be
[Music]
Drive oh my God Flash
hi I love you thank you cring you into
Mr W no please don't I need you here now
Barry so you're saying you can travel
back in
time but Bruce I can fix things I can
save people I can save my mom I can save
your
parents you can also destroy everything
love you Mom I love you too so how was
it this week how school school was
good oh
sh this is mad trippy dude this is
catastrophic this world must die
no
way allad way I'm not going to lose
again it's not Clark my name is Cara I
will help
you interesting group let
help wait he's
Batman you want to get nuts let's get
nuts oh this
rips
we're in uned
territory what do we do we try not to
die are you ready ready let's
go away
the you have fancy
friends no it was a new bir
oh
exact who do you think the best driver
is probably I would dust him in a
lap D all you do is sling video games
with some crazy dreams of racing cars
dad you're the one that told us to
always do something we love you know
what racing cars
cost look around it's not our world
son what is this it's a
contest the best Gran turiso players in
the world get a chance to competes in
professional racing dude this is
real this is
real I'm sorry you really think you're
going to take a kid who plays video
games in their bedroom you're going to
strap them to a 200 mph rocket it'll
tear him to
pieces you can hate me now it's not
going to work the guys who race are
Elite
athletes your kids are scrawny little
gamer kids that's why you coming come on
let's
go St must be a new experience for you
moving your
legs you puked on my lawn there's no
turning back now when you're in a race
the cockpit is going to be 140° F the
g-forces will be twice what an astronaut
experiences upon lift off I can't see
anything hey hey you get extra points
for that in the game Jesus Christ I had
never give up this whole thing is insane
but out of the couch surfing nerds that
you sent me he is the best one you made
it welcome to team
n what's next major leads the other
drivers are going to hate
you whoopsie what your problem part of
the game is called racing but I won't
stop there if you miss a line in the
game you reset
you missed it on the
track you could
die
you I know this
track I've raced it a thousand
times that's what I'm talking
about
[Music]